now they take billions of dollars more
and years and years more to get through
and we are a climate protest by the
group extinction rebellion just streets
away from the u.n headquarters in new
york
the world will be watching this week the
last gathering of global leaders before
vital climate negotiations take place in
just six weeks time
[Applause]
the paris climate deal was agreed in
2015 but experts say it didn't go far
enough and many countries have not met
their commitments
with the clock ticking towards a key
meeting in glasgow in scotland the un
secretary general sounds a little
pessimistic about achieving a new
landmark deal you've been talking about
mistrust taking place between the
developed world and the developing world
do you think that could derail
any agreement and how serious would that
be for the world it can and it would be
extremely serious and we must avoid it
we must reestablish trust
i think it's important that developed
countries understand that they need to
do more in support of developing
countries namely fulfilling their
commitments made in paris but going
beyond that when world leaders gather
here they'll be discussing a wide range
of issues top of the agenda is
afghanistan there'll be a meeting of the
foreign ministers of the countries of
the g20 and then a meeting of the
ministers of the five permanent members
of the un security council this is the
first general assembly attended by
president joe biden he'll chair a
session on covid 19 with the aim of
trying to find a way to vaccinate the
world james bay's al jazeera at the
united nations